[Musique]
Jean-Paul Fitoi, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Et bien, je m'appelle Jean-Paul Fitoui,
je suis professeur.
Est-ce une qualité ? Je ne sais. J'ai
enseigné un peu partout.
euh à l'étranger comme en France et euh
mon dernier emploi en France fut à
l'Institut d'études politiques de Paris
Science Po pour faire cours. J'ai
beaucoup travaillé, j'ai fait beaucoup
de recherches et j'ai beaucoup travaillé
avec Stiglitz
et Felps. Els qui est un autre prix
Nobel et où je travaillais sur la
théorie structuraliste du chômage avec
Stlis sur la mesure.
Vous avez fait un petit passage à
l'OFCE,
un petit passage
89 à 2010.
Oui. 21 21 ans.
C'est quoi l' FCE ?
L'OFCE c'est un centre qu'a créé
Jean-Marcel Janet
qui en fut le premier président.
à qui j'ai succédé
euh
et j'y suis resté 21 ans comme président
et c'est un centre indépendant
qui est indépendant, je dois le dire euh
parce que je n'ai pas tellement
de lieu de me réjouir de la presse, de
l'état de la presse aujourd'hui
qui
tient son indépendance
de son impact.
sur les médias.
En réalité, les
gouvernements ont essayé de lui couper
son budget parce que le FCE est
impertinent.
Je pensais son métier comme devant être
impertinent. Et et finalement, moi je
leur disais, vous pouvez couper le votre
métier, demain je fais une conférence de
presse simple
et et rien ne se passait.
J'ai gardé le budget que je souhaitais.
Donc ils ont joué le jeu.
Donc on va voir ce soir si vous avez la
pertinence de l'impertinent.
Je sais pas
le vous avez à l'OFCE, c'est
l'observatoire des conjonctures
économiques français. C'est ça
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
et économiques.
Merci. Quand vous étiez encore président
en 2008 quand vous avez vu la crise des
subprimes arriver ?
Bien sûr.
Vous l'avez vu arriver ?
Bien sûr on l'a vu arriver.
On l'a vu arriver en raison de la
dichotomie qu'il y avait
entre l'activité économique et
l'extraordinaire
montée des bourses
et du prix de l'immobilier en certains
pays.
Donc on se disait un arbre ne monte pas
au ciel
donc ça va s'arrêter. Non, je me
souviens que aucun de mes amis ne m'a
cru.
Est-ce que vous avez vu aussi le le
Ribor et le Ribor trafiquer ?
Non,
j'en ai entendu parler mais
pour vous dire franchementin,
je ne l'ai pas vu
du tout.
Non.
D'accord. Bon, après ces ces petites
présentations,
on va parler du 21e siècle.
Vous avez 78 ans, vous êtes économiste,
docteur en économie.
Est-ce qu'on peut avoir votre constat de
la situation actuelle
et ses perspectives ?
La situation économique, c'estàd j'ai
beaucoup de difficultés
à dissocier
le politique, l'économique et le social.
Bon, je n'arrive pas.
Donc je dirais la situation globale
politicoéconomique
sociale est très mauvaise comme elle ne
l'a jamais été.
Comme elle ne l'a jamais été parce que
on va entrer dans une crise majeure
massive.
Certes, les gouvernements ont fait un
tête à queue en changeant d'orientation,
mais il n'empêche que la crise est bien
là, que le chômage va exploser, la
précarité va exploser, les inégalités
vont exploser. En réalité, elles sont
déjà exposées, mais c'est masqué par les
politiques économiques qui sont
conduites aujourd'hui dans la plupart
des gouvernements européens. au niveau
social.
Donc le
avant de partir sur le social, quand
vous entendez quoi par ces masqués ?
C'est-à-dire que les injections de
liquidité, la création de la dette
future sur nos générations futures, ce
qui nous permet de rester encore un
petit peu en apesanteur. Voilà. Voilà
voilà voilà.
Vous
dans la perche hein.
Vous me tendez la perche ?
Ouais. Ça vous réveille un peu ?
Bah bien sûr que ça me réveille.
Alors on se réveille.
Voilà quelque chose qui fait partie de
la novellande.
Voilà
la dette et les générations futures.
Ce ne sont pas les générations futures
qui payent la dette.
Les économistes savent très bien qu'en
réalité
les titres de la dette, la valeur
globale des titres de la dette c'est
zéro. Pourquoi ? Parce que ce sont les
Français qui prêtent au français.
Alors si vous
Attendez, attendez attendez. Les
Français, ils prêtent aux français
comment là ? Il y a pas l'État français
qui va emprunter sur les marchés
financiers avec
Oui. Non mais c'est les Français qui
achètent.
Vous êtes sûr que c'est les Français qui
achètent ? C'est pas le Qatar, l'Arabie
Saoudite,
peu importe. Parce que les Français
aussi détiennent des titres de pays
étrangers.
Lesquels ? Le Bangladesh.
Mais non, ils détiennent des titres
américains, des titres allemands.
Croyez-moi qu'ils en détiennent.
Quel volume ?
Beaucoup.
Non, mais beaucoup ça ça c'est pas chez
nous le beaucoup. Beaucoup combien ?
beaucoup je ne saurais vous dire
euh
ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que en
réalité
dans les circonstances présentes, les
agences économiques cherchent à
s'abriter le plus possible, donc à
détenir les titres les plus sûrs.
C'est quoi un titre sûr ? C'est un titre
dont le la valeur en capital ne va pas
s'effondrer.
Et ce titre sûr, pour l'instant, le
titre le plus sûr a parce qu'il est le
plus sûr un rendement négatif.
En d'autres termes, son taux le taux
d'intérêt qui lui est associé est nul
ou négatif.
C'est le cas de l'Allemagne.
C'est même en un sens le cas de la
France.
Ce n'est plus le cas des États-Unis
parce que les États-Unis sont repartis
étaient repartis
avant le Covid dans un cycle de
croissance qui avait échappé aux
Européens.
Un cycle de croissance pour 10 dollars
d'injecté de dette égale 1 dollar de
PIB. C'est ça.
Bah écoutez, tout dépend ce qu'on fait
avec les 10 dollars de dette.
Non mais on est d'accord sur les
chiffres. J'injecte 10, j'en récupère
un.
Ça dépend quelle époque vous raisonnez.
L'année dernière.
Donc si vous injecter l'année dernière
10, vous en récoltez un cette année.
Mais il se peut que si vous comptez sur
10 ans, vous en récoltez 10.
Inchallah.
Ou ou plus.
Ou
oui
ou plus. Ça fonctionnait comme ça si
vous voulez. à votre époque
le problème c'est non pas à mon époque
ça a toujours fonctionné comme ça
une économie fondée chez la dette et qui
a pourtant le meilleur taux de
croissance du monde c'est ce sont les
États-Unis
et qu'on se mettent bien d'accord le
taux de croissance c'est un taux de
croissance réel un taux de croissance
fictif c'est c'est quoi c'est une
appréciation à la louche c'est quoi
quand je quand je mets par exemple la
prostitution dans le le chiffrage du PIB
ou le commercialisme.
Ben malheureusement vous le mettez pas.
Si si si en France en Espagne, en
Espagne.
Il y a certains il y a certains pays qui
ont souhaité que l'on puisse mettre y
compris le commerce de la drogue dans le
PIB mais pour l'instant ce n'est pas
fait. Les conventions internationales ne
le permettent pas. Vous mettez pas le
chiffre la prostitution, vous mettez pas
le chiffre du crime.
Par contre, vous mettez dans le PIB tout
ce qui est fait pour limiter la
violence.
par exemple les gardes du corps,
par exemple la protection des logements.
Bon, donc ça ça fait augmenter le PIB,
ce qui fait dire que l'augmentation du
PIB n'est pas nécessairement quelque
chose de positif puisque un surcroix de
violence dans la société fait augmenter
le PIB. Un surcroix d'accident dans la
société fait augmenter le PIB.
Un surroit de suicide dans la société
fait augmenter le pif.
Consommation de psychotrope aussi.
Évidemment, tout ce qu'on achète
et qui
représente un excès, un surplus par
rapport à la normale fait augmenter le
PIB. Voilà. Bon, pour revenir au taux de
croissance et à la dette, quand
j'injecte 10, c'est que je récupère un,
même quand je suis patron d'une boîte,
je suis un bon patron, j'ai une bonne
perspective, j'ai une bonne vision long
terme, je vais prendre soin de mes
salariés, je c'est bien ou c'est pas
bien ? Parce qu'en général, vous dites
un patron, tu payes 10, tu récupères un,
ça marche pas
ça. Je sais pas si ça marche pas. Non
non,
vous savez, j'ai été euh dans des
conseil d'administration de très très
grande
société. Elles sont très d'été. Elles
sont très les télécomaliens. Non,
pardon. les télécom italiens. Non,
par exemple, par exemple,
bienvenue. Il n'empêche il n'empêche que
lorsqu'on calcule le rendement
sur la durée de vie de l'actif
qui est acheté grâce à la dette, al ce
rendement peut être supérieur à 1 et
donc permettre non seulement de
rembourser la dette mais en plus de
servir un profit et un dividende aux
actionnaires.
Donc
si vous voulez les choses ne sont pas
simples.
Je prends un exemple encore plus
plus évident. La tour efffel. La tour
effel.
Supposons que au moment où on a créé la
tour effel,
on l' créé en s'endettant.
Bon, alors on se dit la tour estfel euh
on s'est endetté. Quel est le rendement
? On va se dire au bout d'un an, c'est
un on s'est endetté pour 10, c'est un.
Mais si on calcule sur un siècle, le
rendement de la tour est felle est la
meilleure affaire que la France est
faite.
Un coup de bol.
Un coup de bol. Non, c'est pas
nécessairement un coup de bol.
Elle était censée démonté.
C'est pas nécessairement un coup de bol.
Elle était censée être démontée la tour
efffel.
Elle était censée être démontée. Ce qui
est un coup de bol, c'est de ne pas la
voir démontée. Comme ce qui est un coup
de bol, c'est que
euh Jupé n'est pas vendu Topson à
l'époque.
À l'époque.
Et Macron qui vend Alstom, ça va ?
Bien sûr que non. Bien sûr que non.
C'est ridicule de brader un actif dont
on sait qu'il a une valeur certaine
et c'est une question de vision de long
terme.
Est-ce que c'est Oui.
Alors, c'est la vision que devrait
porter
notre ami le nouveau commissaire au
plan.
C'est comment il s'appelle ? François.
Voyez ? Voilà. C'est la même.
Et il est pas en prison lui ?
Non mais il est inculpé. Enfin enfin
inculpé, on dit plus inculpé.
On dit mise en examen.
D'accord. Présemption d'innocence. Donc
ça va ?
Oui, ça va.
Ça va,
ça va.
Revenons parce que là, je vous fais
quelques petites diversion hein.
Revenons à la dette.
Alors, la dette la dette
façon on payera pas, on peut la répudier
la dette.
D'abord, on la paye pas.
Ah, toutes les façons, on la rembourse
pas. Pourquoi ? Parce que il y a
plusieurs erreurs que l'on fait à partir
de la dette.
La dette n'est pas remboursée tout
simplement parce que l'État a une
espérance de vie éternelle.
Allez dire ça au Maya.
Ben le
non pas les Maya le peuple Maya n'a pas
survécu.
Si si le peuple a survécu enfin mais les
lieux qu'ils occupaient sont toujours
là.
Bah oui, si Hitler avait gagné la
guerre, l'Europe n'aurait pas été
détruite. Parlez pas de malheur. Non, je
je vous dis les choses de la façon la
plus pédagogique qui soit. Donc un état
ne disparaît pas en principe. Il y en a
quelques-uns qui vont disparaître. du
fait de la colonisation,
du fait de des guerres
fréquemment tribales
et et du fait des guerres de
colonisation
euh conduites dans le passé. Donc si je
vous comprends bien, mais l'État lui va
demeurer. La France
existe depuis 1500 ans
et on pense pas que dans 1500 ans, elle
aurait disparu.
Elle aura peut-être changé de visage.
Le programme
télévision de 20h aura peut-être changé.
Peut-être pas eu la télévision non plus.
Mais mais la France existera encore.
Est-ce qu'un état fait faillite ?
Un état peut faire faillite quand il
emprunte
quand il emprunte en une monnaie
qu'il ne crée pas lui-même
quand il emprunte en devise étrangère.
L'euro c'est une devise étrangère ou pas
?
Mais l'euro c'est une monnaie sur
laquelle aucun état n'a qu' un contrôle.
Aucun État européen ne n'a un contrôle.
Donc c'est comme une devise étrangère.
C'est comme une devise étrangère.
C'est Bot.
Vous pouvez pas la créer. Vous n'avez
pas de contrôle.
C'est balot. Non. Donc on peut faire
faillite avec l'euro.
On peut faire faillite avec l'euro. Bien
sûr. La Grèce a failli faire faillite
avec l'euro.
Donc là on va parler un peu plus
technique, on est d'accord. Là, vous
êtes en train de me conseiller de parier
sur la signature de la France pour faire
par exemple de l'assurance vie parce que
comme la France ne fera jamais défaut,
je peux prendre de l'assurance vie. On
est d'accord ?
Bien sûr,
à fond.
Bien sûr.
À fond. Et en plus, je vous dis quand je
vous dis n' pas de faire jamais défaut
et quand je vous dis qu'elle vit
éternellement, pourquoi est-ce que je
prends le le problème de ce point de
vue-là ? C'est parce que nous, vous et
moi, on a une espéance de vie limitée
surtout.
Donc donc la veille de notre mort,
personne ne va nous prêter.
Et même à quelques distances de notre
mort, personne ne va nous prêter. Mais
l'État, non. L'État peut emprunter à
n'importe quelle époque et rembourser en
empruntant de nouveau.
Il remboursera toujours la dette mais
avec de nouveaux emprunts et il trouvera
toujours quelqu'un pour lui prêter
avec des agences de notation qui va
Mais si les agences de notation
l'embête, il crée la monnaie pour
rembourser.
Non mais non mais on est dans l'euro là,
ça tient plus la route votre
raisonnement. Oui, dans l'euro dans
l'euro non dans l'euro le problème
précisément vous mettez le point sur le
problème de l'euro, c'est que l'euro est
une monnaie
sans souverain
alors que la dette
est souveraine.
Donc ça crée un gatus qui risque de de
nous conduire à la catastrophe. Pourquoi
? Parce que nous vivons dans une
économie où les mouvements de capitaux
sont libres, il y a aucun empêchement à
ce que vous aiez investir en Allemagne,
en Italie ou dans n'importe quel pays de
la zone euro
et vous allez investir en euros. Donc
vos capitaux peuvent partir si vous vous
méfiez du pays dans lequel vous êtes.
Par exemple, vous êtes
la France,
hein.
La France
en Italie.
Non, la France.
La France. Allez, par exemple, vous êtes
la France.
On se méfie de la France. Vous
vous méfiez de la France. Qu'est-ce que
vous faites ?
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi on se méfierait de
la France ?
Vous méfiez de la France parce que vous
pensez qu'elle est mal gouvernée. Par
exemple, par exemple,
vous pensez qu'elle est bien gouvernée
la France ?
N'essayez pas de me faire dire ce que
vous avez envie de dire vous-même.
On apprend pas un vieux singe à faire la
grimace, c'est sûr.
D'accord.
Je ne dis pas ça. Je ne dis pas ça. Euh,
vous avez encore des copains au
gouvernement ? C'est ça.
Pardon ?
Vous avez encore des copains au
gouvernement ? Non,
c'est pas une question de copinage,
c'est une question d'appréciation des
politiques qui sont conduites. Alors, il
y a des politiques que je n'apprécie
pas.
Lesquel ?
Et ben la politique de euh réforme des
retraites, la politique de réforme de
l'indemnisation du chômage, la politique
de réforme du code du travail
et il y a des euh aspects de la
politique que j'apprécie comme la
politique européenne,
enfin la politique europé les tentatives
du président de faire quelque chose de
l'Europe qui pour l'instant rien.
Donc revenons à nos moutons.
Revenons à nos moutons.
La France.
La France on
n pas confiance. Donc
donc on n pas confiance dans la France.
Je me dis, je vais pas détenir un titre
sur la dette française.
Donc je vais essayer d'acheter de la
dette allemande.
Donc je prends mes comptes épargnees, je
les amène en Allemagne et j'achète de la
dette allemande.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? La masse
monétaire française baisse,
la masse monétaire allemande
augmente.
Alors, le fait que la masse monétaire
française baisse fait augmenter le taux
d'intérêt en France
alors qu'il le fait baisser en Allemagne
et on appelle ça le spread.
Donc il va se créer un un différentiel
de taux d'intérêt entre la France et
l'Allemagne. C'est un peu technique tout
ça. Non, non, sera on a une communauté
qui est relativement affutée là-dessus
entre la France entre la France et
l'Allemagne qui fera
payer des intérêts de plus en plus
élevés sur la dette française au point
qu'elle pourrait être en faillite.
Lorsque la Grèce
n'a pu emprunter qu'à 20 %, elle était
sur le bord de la faillite. Il a fallu
que l'Europe, le FMI
avec leur
leur affection
mensuité
leur affection pour les populations
viennent à son secours
viennent à son secours et réduisent
l'espérance de vie des enfants grecs.
Bon,
il est pire que moi.
Il y a il y en a un qui pose la question
"Mais où va cette interview ? Vous
inquiétez pas, on sait où on va. Euh,
revenons à la à la Troyka. C'est quoi la
Troya qui a essayer de faire fondre la
Grèce ?
Et bien, la Troy euh
c'est comme le fond monétaire
international,
c'est le retour.
Ce sont ceux qui ont le pouvoir,
d'accord ? qui ont le pouvoir sur les
pays.
Il
ce n'est pas une question de euh de
corruption.
Ce n'est pas qu'ils vont
se mettre de l'argent dans la poche.
Encore que on peut se demander pourquoi
ils ont fait que la Grèce rembourse
la dette qu'elle avait avec certains
entreprises privées allemandes avant
d'être junior d'être
avant de hein
d'être junior et d'être senior.
Voilà.
D'accord. On a suivi le même truc.
Continuez.
Voilà. avant d'être mise
en en quasi faillite et de ne plus
pouvoir aller sur le marché sur les
marchés pour emprunter.
Alors vous dites mais on se demande
pourquoi
on l'a aidé pour qu'elle rembourse.
Oui mais rembourse.
On se demande pourquoi on ils se
remboursent les amis. C'est ça.
Rembourser les amis. Rembourser les
entreprises du pays.
Du pays. Non mais
est-ce que c'est rembourser les amis ça
?
Est-ce que Est-ce que il y avait des
entreprises du pays qui étaient un petit
peu détenu par des entreprises à nous ?
Est-ce qu'on a renfloué les banques
grecques pour éviter que les banques
françaises se vrutent lamentablement ?
On a renfloué les banques Grèces. On a
renfloué la Grèse pour éviter un que les
banques allemandes
chutent,
deux que les banques françaises chutent
aussi moins que les banques allemandes
parce que les banques allemandes étaient
les plus atteintes vis-à-vis de la
Grèce, beaucoup plus atteintes que les
banques françaises.
Donc les banques françaises étaient
relativement
abritées vis-à-vis d'un désastre grec,
mais pas les banques allemandes.
Donc une des raisons pour lesquelles le
sauvetage de la Grèce a eu lieu,
c'est précisément cela.
C'est l'intérêt qu'avait l'Allemagne
de renflouer la Grèce pour qu'elle
puisse rembourser ses propres
entreprises. 1
2 Une fois la Grèce redevenue
solvable entre guillemets
avec une population appauvrie
précarisée,
une espérance de vie réduite et cetera.
Donc ce qu'a fait l'Allemagne, elle a
racheté les aéroports grecs qui est le
pays dont on sait que le tourisme
était le plus important de l'ensemble
des pays européens en proportion. en
proportion. Donc c'est une bonne affaire
d'acheter les aéroports en s'en
conviendrait et puis elle acheté des
îles grecqu
enfin les entreprises allemandes pas
l'état allemand les entreprises
allemandes ont acheté les aéroports
grecs. Ça, j'estime que c'est de la
braderie.
La brader
braage. Un braquage.
Oui, c'est c'est un braquage. C'est la
braderie et c'est scandaleux parce que
ça appauvrit la Grèce bien davantage
que la dette à laquelle on renonce.
Pourquoi ? Parce que la valeur de ces
biens cédés est beaucoup plus importante
que la valeur de la dette de la Grèce.
Ouais.
L'erreur que l'on fait là, je reviens à
mes travaux avec église. L'erreur que
l'on fait, c'est l'erreur de considérer
que la richesse se mesure par la dette.
C'est pas vrai. La richesse se mesure
par le patrimoine
et le patrimoine c'est d'un côté la
dette mais c'est la somme de la dette et
des actifs.
Si pour rembourser la dette on détruit
les actives, on les vend, on les brade,
alors dans ce cas-là on est plus pauvre
qu'avant.
C'est un peu ce qui s'est passé avec
Alstom chez nous. C'est un peu ce qui
s'est passé avec Oui, c'est un peu ce
qui s'est passé avec beaucoup d'actifs
avec Alstom, c'est sûr.
C'est c'est vendre les bijoux de
famille.
C'est pas vendre les bijoux de famille
parce que
la France n'était pas étranglée.
On vend les bijoux de famille lorsque il
n'y a plus d'autres d'autres issues.
Mais c'est fait par cette espèce de
conception naïve de la globalisation
de la guerre économique.
Non, précisément la globalisation sans
guerre économique.
Il y a pas une guerre économique sur
Astom. Mais bien sûr qu'il y a une
guerre économique. Simplement la
conception de la globalisation qu'on a
fait avaler à l'ensemble des
populations, c'est celle de la
globalisation heureuse.
La globalisation qui permet à tout le
monde d'accéder à de nouvelles
opportunités et donc de devenir de plus
en plus riche
et de plus en plus intelligent.
Mais en réalité,
c'est un monde drôlement globalisé parce
qu'il y a des hyperpuissances, des
superpuissance, des puissances et puis
des citoyens tout courts, si je puis
dire,
et on peut pas dire et on peut pas dire
que dans cette atmosphère là, on a un
équilibre des pouvoirs
et on sait très bien que emporte
la mise celui qui a le plus de pouvoir.
C'est comme sur le marché du travail,
n'est-ce pas ? Vous allez pas aimer ça
puisque vous êtes des entrepreneurs.
Ce sont les entreprises qui veulent leur
pouvoir augmenter lorsque le chômage
augmente.
Non, vous n'aimez pas ça là.
J'ai pas j'ai pas entendu. C'est quoi
les entreprises qui
qui voient leur pouvoir augmenter
lorsque le chômage augmente.
C'est pas notre crédau.
Je sais que c'est pas votre crédau. Non,
je sais que vous n'avez pas comme
objectif de faire croître le chômage
pour voir votre pouvoir augmenter.
Mais ce que je dis, en conséquence de
l'augmentation du chômage, il y a un
affaiblissement du pouvoir de
négociation des salariés. C'est une
évidence
et
que vous ne pouvez pas nier.
C'est vrai. Et revenons à la Grèce. On a
castré la Grèce pour lui empêcher de de
On a castré la Grèce
pour l'empêcher de mouffer derrière.
C'est ça. Pour l'empêcher de de se
plaindre. On lui a enlevé sa capacité.
capter la Grèce parce que on on
souhaitait donner une leçon à l'Europe
en disant voilà ce qui arrive lorsque
vous ne suivez pas les règles
européennes
et la Grèce en tant que petit pays
n'avait pas d'inconvénients systémiques
si je puis dire sur l'ensemble de la
zone euro ou sur l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne. Bon, ça part sur les
banques.
Sur les banques, mais les banques, vous
savez, en réalité les banques sont
subventionnées par les banques centrales
et donc nous.
Évidemment,
évidemment, c'est le contribuable infiné
qui subventionne les banques. Ce ne sont
pas les banques qui subventionnent le
contribuable. Donc si une banque va mal,
on a fait l'expérience
de l'anxérience
de l'emm aperçu que c'était une
catastrophe inuie mondiale. Une banque
une banque ça a été une catastrophe
mondiale. On a dit plus jamais ça. Donc
maintenant on laissera plus jamais une
banque faireite on viendra sur ce coût
de deux façons. Soit en la renflouant
soit en la nationalisant. Mais c'est la
même chose
ou soit en changeant les lois.
Comment en changeant les lois ? Si elles
sont en faillite, si elles n'ont pas de
quoi payer euh les euh déposants,
on a beau changé la loi, euh ça changera
pas cet aspect-là des choses. Il faut
bien qu'on leur donne de l'argent pour
qu'elle rembourse les déposants.
La Troyka, revenons à la Troya. Ils sont
élus, ils sont pas élus ? C'est quoi ces
gens-là ?
Vous venez au problème de la démocratie.
C'est ça.
Alors, si vous voulez le
le fond monétaire international n'est
pas élu,
les institutions européennes ne sont pas
élues.
Donc, vous avez
euh un un problème démocratique évident,
un déficit démocratique. On pourra vous
dire que les institutions européennes
sont nommées par des personnes élues,
les conseils, les chefs d'État,
mais elles sont nommées, ils sont nommés
à l'unanimité. Bon
donc si vous avez la commission et la
banque centrale
qui agissent sur un pays
et bien c'est comme un dénis de
démocratie parce qu'en principe ce pays
devrait être souverain.
Alors on dira pourquoi il a voulu s'unir
avec les autres pays à accepter la loi
de l'Union.
Peut-être parce que il n'imaginait pas
que la loi de l'Union allait stagner.
L'Europe jusqu'à présent était faite par
petit pas. Un pas conduisait à un autre.
Lorsqu'on a fait la monnaie unique, on
s'est dit
le ministère des finances va suivre. Le
ministère des finances n'a jamais suivi.
Donc on s'est trouvé dans un système
profondément déséquilibré.
Un système qui a affaibli l'Europe au
point d'en faire le ventre mou de la
globalisation.
On fait quoi ? On sort de l'Europe, on
fait un frexit.
Mais non, pourquoi
on fait on fait
quand quand je vous écoute,
fait une Europe fédérale.
Non mais d'accord,
écoutez, moi je critique l'Europe telle
qu'elle est. Je vais pas critiquer
l'Europe
telle qu'elle aurait pu être. Je
critique l'Europe telle qu'elle est.
Donc l'Europe telle qu'elle est est mal
construite.
Il y a des défauts de construction. Bon
ça arrive hein, on peut se tromper. Dans
un immeuble lorsqu'il y a des défauts de
construction, on répare ces défauts de
construction. Après ça
laisse pas l'immeuble s' vendré.
Non mais on n'est pas en Italie, on est
d'accord. Mais on n'est pas en Italie,
on est d'accord. Mais quand quand on
voit quand on voit que structurellement
parlant,
ça va être très très très long à
résoudre.
On fait quoi ? On continue de rester au
soleil ou on arrête et on recommence sur
des bases plus saines.
Où est-ce que ce système est
inextricable ?
Oui. Oui, on peut dire ça.
Bah moi je crois qu'on a euh
une alternative
bah soit d'aller vers la fédération mais
il faut le faire vite.
C'est quoi vite ?
C'est demain. Vous savez c'est pas on a
pas besoin de créer d'emblé une
fédération. Il suffit de créer une
autorité budgétaire commune. Ça suffit.
Si on crée une autorité budgétaire
commune et on peut la créer, on n'est
pas très loin
de pouvoir créer une autorité budgétaire
commune. On est déjà dans une
fédération. N'oubliez pas qu'il existe
des institutions fédérales en Europe. La
Banque centrale européenne, la Cour de
justice européenne et la euh le
commissaire à la concurrence.
de de l'Europe qui a le pouvoir
exécutif, législatif et judiciaire.
Donc, ce sont des instances fédérales.
Donc, on a créé une instance fédérale
avec la monnaie, on peut créer une
instance fédérale avec le budget.
Qu'est-ce qui empêche ? Qu'est-ce qui
est plus important, la monnaie ou le
budget ?
Personne n'est capable de vous répondre
à cette question.
La monnaie, c'est que c'est l'attribut
majeur de la souveraineté du prince.
Et pourtant, on a commencé par
fédéraliser la monnaie.
Donc on peut aller dans cette direction
là ou si on narrive pas à aller dans
cette direction là, si on narrive pas à
récupérer la souveraineté que nous avons
perdu
et qui nous empêche de conduire les
politiques que nous souhaitons conduire,
alors on reprend nos billes
parce qu'on a besoin d'une souveraineté.
C'est quoi reprend nos billes ?
C'est-à-dire la souveraineté redevient
nationale. On sort de l'Europe.
On sort pas de l'Europe. On restera dans
l'Europe mais on on sort de la zone
euro. Point point bas.
C'est possible ça ?
On n'y était pas avant.
C'est possible de maintenant de faire
marche arrière de faire
pourra pas.
On pourra pas.
Je dis pas pourquoi pas.
Ah pourquoi pas ?
Je ne dis pas que ce sera euh une
promenade, je dis pas que ça sera
facile, mais ce n'est pas impossible.
Pourquoi serait-ce possible ?
Je prends un exemple à dessin
simple.
Supposons qu'un pays est un programme de
développement formidable
et qui dit "J'en ai marre de ces
contraintes européennes. Je sors
de l'Europe,
je mets en œuvre mon programme de
développement, je me développe comme je
le pensais. Je vais être le pays le plus
puissant d'Europe."
L'Allemagne, quoi.
Pourquoi voulez-vous qu'il m'arrive
malheur ? L'Allemagne, si l'Allemagne
sortait de l'Europe, l'Allemagne
perdrait énormément.
Son avant son avantage concurrentiel
avec la monnaie, c'est ça ?
Oui, elle a un avantage concurrentiel
d'avoir une monnaie sous-évaluée.
Une monnaie sous-évaluée, c'est-à-dire
une monnaie qui lui permet des gains de
compétitivité
en permanence.
Donc on va continuer sur l'Europe. Le
plan de relance européen, vous l'avez
regardé un petit peu à la précément
voulez-vous je l' pas regardé.
Alors, vous l'avez regardé du côté
italien ou du côté français ?
J'ai regardé de tous les côtés.
D'accord. Alors, nous les français, on
va mettre 80 sur la table, c'est ça ? Et
on va récupérer 40,
c'est ça ?
Oui. Comment vous calculez ? Ah bah moi
je calcule vite hein. Vous savez ce qui
sort de ma poche et ce qui rentre dans
ma poche. C'est très vite.
Mais disons que pour l'Italie c'est
l'inverse
pour un idéaliste.
Pour l'Italie.
Ah pour l'Italie. L'Italie euh ils sont
quand même euh
ils vont avoir 80 milliards et ils vont
payer 40. Donc c'est je disais c'est
l'inverse le Portugal au chiffre
français.
En gros disons
que c'est l'inverse pour bien montrer
cela. Mais de quoi s'agit-il en réalité
? Il s'agit d'une mutualisation
de la dette
mutualisation d'une partie de la dette.
On ne rembourse pas une dette, on paye
ses cotisations au budget européen.
C'est le budget européen qui est
empreinte.
C'est la Commission qui est empreinte.
et au lieu et qui prête
ou qui donne à partir de ce qu'elle a
emprunté et qui se fait payer par les
contributions des États.
Les États vont contribuer à hauteur de
leur quota qui est ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui. Le quot français étant
supérieur
à ce que la France a envisager de
percevoir,
bah la France va avoir à payer sur la
durée de l'emprunt qui peut être 10 ans.
Vous comprenez ? pas tout de suite que
que la France va payer 80 milliards et
toucher 40 milliards. Elle va toucher 40
milliards. Elle devrait toucher 40
milliards tout de suite. Mais les 80
milliards, elle va les payer sur 10 ans
si ce n'est sur plus
avec un taux d'intérêt
zéro. Actuellement le taux d'intérêt est
zéro.
Actuellement, c'est c'est le bonheur des
débiteurs.
On est dans une situation où celui qui
ne s'endettete pas est un imbécile,
excusez-moi.
Donc, je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
fait tout ce problème avec la dette.
Mais ce qui m'avait fait bondier
dans votre affirmation tout à l'heure,
sûr,
sur la dette, c'est que vous me avez
parlé des générations futures.
Combien ? Combien on est méchant avec
les générations futures lorsqu'on
s'endettete parce que ce sont les
générations futures qui vont rembourser.
C'est pas vrai.
Ils vont jamais rembourser. Ils vont
simplement prendre plus d'impôt.
Non non non non. En admettant que la
dette soit remboursée,
ce ne sont pas les générations futures.
Ça n'a jamais ça n'a jamais été les
générations futures qui ont remboursé la
dette.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que
les générations futures hérites de quoi
? De la dette.
Et des actifs
et de la créance.
La créance.
Donc ils écrit d'un actif net nul.
Donc il payent pas. Vous voyez ? Vous
comprenez ? Bon alors c'est
arithmétiquement tellement évident que
je ne comprends pas qu'on continue à
m'embêter à me chauffer les oreilles
avec les générations futures et avec
notre bonisme. On aime tellement les
générations futures que les premières
victimes des politiques d'austérité que
l'on a conduit jusque-là, ce sont les
jeunes.
Bon,
c'est les générations futures qui sont
avec nous.
Un peu les vieux aussi. Alors qu'on bon
les vieux de toutes les façons, on est
en train de se débarrasser avec le Covid
mais
je vous ai fait perdre votre fil
mais là je veux dire on a des
générations futures avec nous et on les
fait souffrir le martyre ces générations
s'en foutent de la dette par contre
elles ne s'en foutent pas de
l'investissement en école en université
en infrastructur structure
en système de soins,
en système de santé, en en système de
retraite. Non,
c'est ça qu'elle se que les générations
futures souhaitent. Non, pas d'avoir la
dette la plus faible possible
puisqu'elles héritent en même temps du
titre de la dette. Bon, de la créance.
Bon, je on on pousse, c'est pour ça que
ça m'énerve.
On pousse le raisonnement.
Oui.
Madagascar, vous en pensez quoi ?
Ben, je connais pas l'histoire. Vous
connaissez pas l'histoire de Madagascar
? Bon, c'est pas grave. Prenons Non,
non, non. Prenons un pays, n'importe
lequel en Afrique
très très très endetté comme le
Zimbabweé avec une monnaie avec euh des
des milliers de zéos sur les billets de
banque.
Et pourquoi ils ont pas continué à
s'endetter, à créer de la monnaie, à
créer de la monnaie ? parce qu'ils sont
endettés en devise étrangère
en euros quoi.
Ils sont endettés en dollars en gros
et
pour rembourser des dollars euh il
commence à devenir insolvable.
C'est
ils ont beau créé leur monnaie
nationale. Il faut tellement de valises
pour payer un pain euh enfin une
baguette.
que le le l'échange ne peut avoir lieu
entre la monnaie nationale et les
devises étrangères dans lesquelles ils
sont endettés. Donc c'est ça le problème
des pays en développement et de leur
dette. D'autre part,
l'hyperinflation, puisque vous parlez
d'hyperinflation,
de
de de prix absolument démesuré,
l'hyperinflation généralement
c'est la conséquence de la corruption.
C'est pas la conséquence de
l'endettement,
c'est la conséquence de la corruption du
fait que
le le le prince
fabrique de la monnaie
pour aider
sa clientèle.
Ce n'est pas du tout la dette qui génère
l'hyperinflation.
Qu'est-ce qui crée la stackflation ?
C'est la résultante de quoi la
stackflation ? La circflation, c'est une
circonstance qu'on a connu une fois euh
dans laquelle on a simultanément une
aggravation du chômage et de
l'inflation.
On y est pas hein, franchement, on y est
pas.
Actuellement, on a la trouille d'avoir
une déflation,
comprenez ? Et on a du chômage, une
aggravation du chômage, c'est dessus.
Mais on a la trouille d'avoir une
déflation, pas une inflation. La
saflation, c'était les années 70.
Et il était normal qu'on ait cette
stacflation parce que le prix des
matières premières avait été multiplié
par bah du pétrole avait été multiplié
par 6. Donc comme les le pétrole est
importé, ça fait augmenter
tous les fabrications, tous les produits
qui utilisent le pétrole dans leur
fabrication
et donc tous les prix et mais ça n'a
pas du tout euh eu cette élément que
l'on essaie d'insuffler aux gens,
de dire que l'inflation était devenue un
phénomène.
indépendant du chômage parce que à ce
moment-là,
on avait construit une théorie en disant
bah vous voyez la flation montre que
n'importe quel taux d'inflation est
compatible avec un taux de chômage
donné. C'est pas vrai. C'est pas vrai.
On le voit bien depuis quand le chômage
augmente, le taux d'inflation baisse.
Là, c'était un phénomène exogène qui est
une augmentation du prix du pétrole dû à
une augmentation du pouvoir de
négociation
des pays producteurs de pétrole. Il se
sont dit "On va pas se laisser avoir, on
va se mettre ensemble, on va les faire
chanter." Et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait.
Si je vous dis est-ce que vous avez lu
un bouquin, on m'attire mon attention
sur internet, est-ce que vous avez lu un
bouquin qui s'appelle confession d'un
assassin économique
de John Perkins.
Non, vous savez ma culture est très très
limitée.
Oui, la nôtre aussi.
Nouvelle nouvelle révélation d'initié
sur la manipulation des économies du
monde. Est-ce que vous avez vu des
manipulation sur les économies du monde
quand vous étiez
opérationnel à l'OFCE
ou quand vous étiez conseiller du
président ?
Je vous considère comme étant toujours
opérationnel
dans les dans les postes que j'occupe.
Je je n'ai pas une vision complotiste du
monde.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez complotiste
?
On est manipulé le si on est manipulé,
je voudrais bien savoir par qui je vous
je vous donne un exemple. Le ribord,
ça a été manipulé ou ça a pas été
manipulé ?
Écoutez qu'il y ait des intérêts.
Le ribor, il a été manipulé ou il a pas
été c'est complotiste ou c'est pas
complotiste ? Non, il a été manipulé par
des gens qui avaient intérêt à le
manipuler et qui ont fait fortune.
C'estd ce n'est pas un système global.
Il y avait pas des états derrière ?
Non.
Non, je crois pas.
Je crois pas.
C'était des systèmes bancaires et
Ouais. Oui.
Vous vous pensez qu'il y avait des états
derrière ? Je pense rien du tout. Je
pose des questions. Bon, c'est sorti 6
ans après, mais on a vu que le Ribor et
le ROR était manipulé. sorti 6 ans
après. Tant que j'ai pas vu, j'ai pas
vu.
Donc je veux dire, je peux dire tout ce
que vous voulez 6 ans après simplement
je me méfie de cette vision complotise.
Alors je on reprend.
On est manipulé.
D'accord. Stop. On est manipulé. On n
pas manipulé dans le cas d'
l'Argentine l'Argentine et les fonds
vautours. C'était quoi
l'Argentine ? C con particulièrement
bien l'Argentine.
C'est vrai.
Oui, particulièrement bien l'Argentine.
Avant la grande crise argentine, j'avais
fait une conférence de presse à Benacer
où je disais "Vous allez dans le mur et
ça va se passer très vite."
Bon, le gouvernement argentin a interdit
aux journaux de reproduire mes propos. 2
mois après, l'Argentine était dans la
plus grave crise de son existence.
Donc maintenant ce qui se passe c'est
que cette crise n'est pas purgée.
Est-ce qu'il y a des extérieurs derrière
ou pas ? Elle n'est pas terminée. Il y a
il y a et là je participe à tout un
courant avec des économistes
internationaux et notamment Siglit
pour essayer de sauver l'Argentine.
Et pour essayer de sauver l'Argentine
euh il nous faut absolument persuader
ces fonds qui veulent être remboursés
euh au au dollar le dollar voyez.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ne veulent faire
aucune concession
à leur créance sur l'Argentine.
Et donc la question que l'on se pose,
c'est quelle est la raison
d'une attitude aussi conne. Excusez-moi.
Quelle est la raison ?
Je dis une bêtise.
Alors,
quelle est la raison ? Parce que si vous
voulez, il y a un modèle
dans en économie auquel je crois, c'est
le modèle proie prédateur.
Ah voilà.
Bon, le modèle pro prédateur, c'est le
modèle que nous avons dans la nature et
en principe ça s'équilibre parce que les
prédateurs
ne prélèvent que la surpopulation des
proies.
Donc il ne tue pas l'ensemble des proies
parce que s'il tuait l'ensemble des
proies
euh non prédateur
oui s'il tuit l'ensemble des pro, ils
mourrait eux-mêmes de faim.
C'est la même chose entre créancier et
débiteur.
Si le créancier tue le débiteur, il ne
sera jamais remboursé.
Donc il sera lui-même en faillite.
Il faut juste le maintenir en vie comme
il faut. Et oui, c'est c'est la pratique
des créanciers dans le monde entier de
maintenir en vie.
Enfin, je
revenons, revenons sur les manipulations
de marché.
Vous avez de de avec votre longue
carrière et votre longue expérience
peut-être avec les marchés
arrêtez d'insister sur le fait qu'elle
est long. D'accord.
Vous avez vu des arrê Vous avez vu
vous avez vu des manipulations sur les
marchés financiers ou pas ?
Est-ce que j'ai vu des manipulations sur
les marchés ? Oui, bien sûr que j'ai vu
des manipulations sur les marchés. Alors
les manipulations un marché
euh sont essentiellement des
manipulations sur un marché de change
et de matière première de temps en
temps.
sur les marchés de matière première, sur
les marchés de change et ce sont des
manipulations
ou qui ont un objectif tout à fait
précis
pour ce qui concerne les marchés de
matière première, c'est pour permettre
au prix d'augmenter
ou au contraire au prix de s'effondrer
selon les pays qui s'adonnent à la
manipulation. pour les manipulations
chez marché de champ,
c'est pour permettre au pays de gagner
en compétitivité.
On a reproché euh au Japon d'avoir fait
son développement sur une monnaie
sous-évaluée
et on reproche aujourd'hui à la Chine de
faire la même chose.
Donc on dit la Chine manipule le marché.
Mais le problème vous êtes en capacité
de manipuler pour l'exemple de la Chine
le marché d'échange que parce que vous
avez une arme.
L'arme de la Chine c'est quoi ? L'arme
de la Ch, ce sont les titres de la dette
qu'elle détient, la dette américaine
qu'elle détient. Parce que si elle
vendait ses titres de la dette
américaine, il veut il vaudrait zéro.
Vous voyez ?
Revenons au plan de relance européen.
Ouais.
Donc on met 80 sur la table, on récupère
40 mais on va récupérer 40 et on va
demander qu'on fasse des petites
ajustations. Des
on met pas 80 sur la table. Excusez-moi,
j'insiste. On touche 40 et on rembourse
en 10 ans. Ouais. Non mais il y a des
gens qui ont des cartes bleues avec
débit différé. Il y a des gens qui ont
des cartes bleues avec débit immédiat.
Moi, je raisonne comme ça. En débit
immédiat, je ne vis pas à crédit.
Mais écoutez là, les États vivent à
crédit. Vous pouvez pas supprimer les
États.
Non, mais d'accord, laissez-moi
terminer.
Ils vivent pas comme vous.
D'accord. Donc là, là je vais je vais
cotiser 80000. Je vais cotiser 80
milliards. En gros, je vais cotiser 40
milliards, on est d'accord. Je cise 40
milliards
net
net. Et derrière, on va me demander de
tailler dans mes retraites. C'est bien,
c'est pas bien. Est-ce que c'est un
petit peu la carotte, la haine, le bâton
?
Attendez.
Allez, dites-moi.
Vous vous faites que le temps redevienne
un point. H
Or, le temps est une flèche.
Un vecteur
le temps est une flèche. Cela signifie
que en réalité
d'ici 10 ans, vous ne savez pas où sera
conduite l'économie du fait des
investissements qui auront été faits
avec cet argent qui aura été
immédiatement disponible
grâce au plan européen.
Il se peut que les économies européennes
deviennent beaucoup plus productives.
Elle est bonne en Italie, hein.
Ça renvoie beaucoup plus. N'oubliez pas
que l'Italie est le deuxième pays
industriel d'Europe, hein.
Oui, oui, oui. Surtout le nord, quoi.
N'oubliez pas ça. Et n'oubliez pas que
c'est un pays où le luxe
est une industrie très très florissante
et où la qualité de vie est
exceptionnelle
et que si l'on mesurait
le euh l'indicateur
de bien-être, le bien-être en Italie
serait bien plus élevé qu'il ne l'
pays européens,
peut-être à l'exception de la France,
parce que ce sont les deux pays où il
fait bon vivre. Euh non, enfin je ferme
la la parenthèse.
Donc il faut pas rire de l'Italie.
Ah non, on ne rit pas.
Bon,
j'avais eu l'impression
j'avais eu cette impression. Bon, je me
suis trompé.
Donc ce que je voulais dire c'est que le
les
investissements peuvent avoir eu des
rendements assez considérables qui
permettent de continuer avec des
cotisations moindres pour la retraite.
Alors si ça marche pas,
vous vous placez dans l'hypothèse où ça
marche pas
où ce plan ne marche pas.
C'est possible. C'est possible. Le CCE
pareil,
le sud partout, c'est possible que le
plan ne marche pas.
Alors, il y a deux attitudes. On redoule
d'ardeur,
c'est un replan de relance.
Ouais, on relance.
On redouble.
D'accord.
Comme aux États-Unis
qui sont propriétaires de leur monnaie.
Il redoubl. Oui, ils sont propriétaires
de leur monnaie. Nous nous
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure,
nous on l'a un peu
nous en tant que français on
on l' dans l'os
aucun de nos pays ne sont nés
propriétaires de la monnaie mais on
pourrait l'être si on faisait une
fédération c'est la seule question alors
mais je comprends pas et je vous coupe
un peu. Je je suis désolé mais il y a
sur certains euros, il y a des euros
allemands, il y a des euros français.
Non, pas du tout.
Non,
pas du tout.
mais il y a ce que l'on appelle des taux
de change interne
qui sont qui n'existent pas. Ce sont des
constructions euh arithmétiques.
C'est juste le taux de change corrigé du
rapport de prix.
et on obtient à partir de là le taux de
change interne, taux de change réel
interne et qui mesure la compétitivité
du pays.
Donc si dans un pays les prix augmentent
moins vite que dans un autre, et bien ce
pays gagne en compétitivité.
C'est comme si ça monnaie d'évaluer.
Donc il a ce que l'on appelle, il
bénéficise de ce que l'on appelle une
dévaluation interne. Et l'Allemagne
c'est le champion des dévaluations
internes.
C'est la raison pour l'Allemagne pour
laquelle l'Allemagne a
un excédent considérable. Et c'est la
raison aussi pour laquelle l'Allemagne a
intérêt que l'euro
continue parce que si l'euro s'arrêter,
l'Allemagne n'aurait plus cet avantage
parce que les autres pays dévalueraient
nominalement pour contrer la dévaluation
interne de l'Allemagne. Voyez ?
Bon,
donc le plan de relance dans un système
où tout va bien, on a une bonne lecture,
on a une des bons des bons actuaires qui
anticipe le risque, on a on a une une
bonne anticipation des risques, on se
fait un petit plan de relance à 80
milliards, tout va bien. Dans 10 ans, on
récupère nos billes x 10. Si je vous
suis, c'est ça.
Bon, je vous je vous décris un peu le
contexte du 21e siècle. On est dirigé
par une bande d'arriviste
avec des cabinets de conseil avec des
cabin Ouais, on est d'accord avec des
cabinets de conseil qui n'en valent pas
moins, où les moquettes sont très
épaisses, où ils ont jamais rien vu
venir, où ils ont jamais rien anticipé
mais ils sont toujours en poste. On va
injecter de la de l'argent dans ce
système overstretch hypertendu.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand il y a un
événement exotique extérieur comme le
Covid qui débarque ? avec des leaders
faibles,
une résilience qui est égale à
zéro.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Bon, je vois que ça va être très
difficile de vous rendre optimiste. Je
parfaitement optimiste.
Oui. Non,
je me fais l'avocat du diable.
C'est pas évident d'après ce que vous
dit.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Il y a une différence entre être
optimiste et être lucide.
Vous connaissez la différence ?
Oui, je sais, je sais, je sais.
L'optimisme.
L'optimisme c'est euh comment dis-je-il
ce quel était le
le proverbe ?
Je vous laisse.
Et ben j'ai oublié. Oui.
Alors c'était l'optimisme.
Bon pass on retrouvera le proverbe. On
va demander à le pessimisme et
l'optimisme.
On va demander à notre communauté nous
nous retrouver les proverbes si vous
voulez. Ouais.
Donc revenons à notre contexte. Des
leaders faibles, des cabinets de
d'anticipation
relativement improductif, aveugle voire
borgne dans le meilleur des cas.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans un système
hypertendu quand il y a un événement
extérieur exotique qui va un petit peu
perturber le rondrond quotidien des
formations et de l'éducation de rondron
quotidien où on a toujours appris à
faire perdurer le rondron quotidien ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Je vais
répondre à votre question de deux
façons.
La première est de dire que si vous
partez de l'hypothèse qu'on est gouverné
par des cons et bien rien ne se passera
du fait du plan de relance.
Ils sont pas cons. Ils sont pas cons.
Ils ont juste les dents qui traînent par
terre.
Ils sont égoïstes.
Voilà,
c'est la même chose. Donc c'est pas des
gouvernants.
C'est pas des gouvernants. Ça veut dire
on n'est pas gouverné en gros
si on est gouverné par des gens qui ne
pensent qu'à eux.
Alors que le gouvernement, c'est de
penser au bien commun. C'est ça qui
signifie un gouvernement. Donc si vous
me dites qu'on est gouverné par des
égoïstes, alors évidemment rien ne peut
réussir. Rien ne peut réussir. Ils s'en
mettront plein les fouilles et plein les
fouilles à leurs amis.
C'est un peu ce qui s'est passé depuis
des années, non ?
Ben,
il n'y a pas eu de plan de relance, vous
voyez.
Où ? Où ? À l'échelle européenne.
À l'échelle européenne, il y en a on a
pas eu on n pas eu des LTR des choses
comme ça.
Ça c'est la la banque centrale qui a
sauvé l'Europe.
Ouais. Non mais c'est à peu près pareil.
C'est un plan de relance à l'échelle de
la banque centrale.
Non, elle a sauvé les banques.
Ouais. Non mais d'accord, c'est pas un
plan de relance. C'est pas un plan de
relance parce que si vous voulez un plan
de relance
monétaire, c'est
mon dieu que les choses sont complexes.
Si vous voulez, on est dans ce qui est
simple clairement.
On est dans une situation qu'on appelle
trappe à liquidité.
C'est une situation où queles que soit
les liquidités que vous injectez dans le
secteur ne sont pas dépensées.
Donc en réalité,
plus vous injectez de liquidité, moins
la masse monétaire croit. Il y a pas de
croissance de la masse monétaire.
La communauté vous coupe et vous dit
"L'optimisme vient de Dieu, le
pessimiste est né et le pessimisme est
né du dans le cerveau de l'homme."
C'est possible.
Le pessimiste est un optimiste bien
informé, proverbe russe.
Un très beau proverbe.
Donc les trappes à liquidité.
Donc
donc je disais
que en réalité la trappe à liquidité
c'est une situation où quelle que soit
la politique de la banque centrale elle
ne peut pas être expansionniste,
elle ne peut pas avoir d'effets
parce que les gens ne veulent pas
dépenser,
ils ne veulent ni consommer ni investir.
les entreprises se trouvent dans un état
d'incertitude telle qu'elles ne veulent
pas investir.
Les
euh les consommateurs sont dans un état
de précarité tel qu'ils préfèrent
épargner plutôt que d'investir. Dans ce
cas-là, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
C'est la déflation.
On risque la déflation.
Et et donc
ce qu'a fait la banque, c'est les
banques centrales dans le monde,
bien ils ont juste évité la déflation,
rien fait d'autre parce que
dans une situation de trappe à
liquidité, la politique monétaire est
impuissante.
Elle est totalement impuissante.
Alors ce qui est au contraire dans une
situation de trappe à liquidité très
puissante, c'est la politique
budgétaire.
On la politique budgétaire, c'est celle
qui était empêchée
avant le Covid.
Je dis pas avant le Covid, avant le 17
juillet 2020.
C'était la politique budgétaire qui
était empêchée.
Je signale qu'on est en
le 10 septembre ou le 11 septembre, je
sais plus.
Oui, le 10.
On est le 10 septembre et et que le plan
de relance n' pas vu le début d'un
commencement, hein.
C'est c'est c'est des prophéties
incantatoires. C'est quoi ? du
non c'est pour vous dire que plus on se
presse àement moins plus on se
presse
lentement moins on a de chance d'arriver
à quel résultat que ce soit dans une
situation dans dans laquelle on se
trouve donc pour revenir à on a bloqué
la politique budgétaire qui était la
seule politique efficace
dans un système
de trappe à liquidité
Et ce blocage de la politique budgétaire
a fait en sorte que
rien n'était possible pour combattre le
Covid.
Alors affolé, les gouvernements se sont
sentis obligés de faire quelque chose.
La première chose qu'ils ont faite,
c'est de mettre entre parenthèses et
règles budgétaires. Attention, de mettre
entre parenthèses et règles budgétaires,
pas de les supprimer.
Ça veut dire qu'elles vont revenir au
galot
et
on s'est mis un peu en apesanteur quoi.
Pas
on est on a été un peu en apesanteur.
Voilà,
j'en profite pour vous couper
l'intelligence du pessimiste et la
volonté de l'optimiste.
Exactement.
Euh et donc euh
il y a cette
bah vous m'avez coupé et je perds le fil
de
C'est pas grave. Je vous lance je vous
lance sur quelque chose d'autre. Je vous
lance sur quelque chose d'autre.
C'est quoi les débats économiques
interdits maintenant ?
C'est sortir de l'Eur, sortir de
l'Europe. C'est quoi si vous voulez
ce qui est interdit ?
Aujourd'hui, c'est ce que je dis dans
mon livre que vous n'avez pas cité
jusqu'à présent.
On cite pas les livres ici.
Euh
et bien ce sont des mots simples.
Augmentation des salaires. Et bah
c'est quelque chose. C'est
c'est un gros mot hein. Augmentation des
salaires. Bon, tu as compris ?
Je ça
euh
qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme autre gros mot
politique budgétaire expansionniste ? On
va en faire un peu mais très limité dans
le temps comme on l'a fait après la
crise
financière de 2007. Bon, après, on a
toujours fait et un an après, on a pris
tellement peur qu'on est revenu à une
politique d'austérité dingue.
Euh, c'est pas trop vrai ça quand même,
non ?
Hein ?
Non, on n' pas envoyé la planche à
liquidité de la planche à taquet. Non,
la planche habillée
n'est pas le moyen encore une fois n'est
pas un moyen de relance lorsque
l'économie
est un jus de croissance.
négative.
Une croissance négative récession. C'est
ça.
Oui, c'est ça.
D'accord. Bah pourquoi vous appelez pas
une récession une récession ?
Mais appeler récession, une récession
croissance négative
négative.
Croissance négative. On comprend.
C'est un peu comme demi-mol, non ?
On comprend.
Demiol. Ouais, on comprend tout de
suite. Mais croissance négative pour
moi, ça veut rien dire.
Ça veut dire que le taux de croissance
est négatif. Ça veut dire que alors je
vais vous expliquer, je vais être encore
plus clair.
Négative, ça veut dire diminution du
PIB. Ça va, c'est clair. Diminution du
PIB.
Le PIB c'est le revenu national disons.
Non, diminution du revenu national. Ça
ça veut dire croissance négative.
C'est ça de la novel langue ?
croissance négative, c'est de la novel
langue.
Non
non
non, c'est pas la novel langue parce que
tout le monde comprend. Il y a rien de
caché dans le mot croissance négative.
Par contre, lorsque l'on cherche à vous
faire croire
qu'il y a d'un côté le salaire net perçu
et de l'autre côté les charges sociales,
on est en plein langue.
C'est cotisation sociale.
Charges, on dit on dit
on dit plus cotisation dans la no langue
maintenant. Non, nous on dit toujours
charge social, on dit il faut baisser
les charges sur les salaires. Les
entreprises disent
dans un cœur unanime, il faut baisser
les charges les charges nous étouffent.
C'est pas les cotisations. Les
cotisations n'étouffent personne. Ce
sont les charges qui étouffent. Donc les
charges nous étouffent. Donc il faut
baisser les charges sociales.
Bon, on va baisser les charges sociales.
Avant, comment on appelait
ce couple ? salaire net charge sociale
salaire direct
salaire différé
parce que ce qu'on appelle charge
sociale c'est ce qui permet de financer
l'assurance maladie l'assurance chômage
et les retraites. Donc quand on veut
baisser les charges sociales, ça veut
dire qu'on veut baisser le système de
protection sociale.
C'est pas c'est pas rien hein. On est en
train de détricoter ce que le Conseil de
la Résistance
a fait
au moment en 1945
pour essayer de sauver le pays de
enfin de de de des plus grands dangers,
la famine, la destruction et cetera. Et
il a réussi, il a réussi au-delà de
toute espérance.
Et maintenant, pourquoi il a réussi à
l'époque ?
Parce que c'était
structurellement parlant, c'était encore
possible.
Évidence,
en 45, vous aviez quel âge ?
3 ans.
3 ans ?
Ouais.
Il y avait combien de millions
d'habitants sur terre ?
Oui, il y en a. Regardez en France,
est-ce que le nombre d'habitants a a
beaucoup augmenté en France ?
Est-ce que le gâteau économique, le
gâteau des ressources est pas en train
de se réduire ? Et c'est pour ça qu'on
est en train de perdre notre protection
sociale.
Le gâteau des ressources n'est pas en
train de se réduire.
Non, il n'est pas en train de se
réduire.
Les inégalités sont en train de croître.
Et quand les inégalités croissent, vous
avez une proportion de plus en plus
grande
population dont les cotisations sont
faibles
et une proportion de plus en plus petite
dont les cotisations sont élevées. Au
total, si vous faites la somme, vous
avez une somme de cotisation très
faible.
Voyez
si G qui augmente de 10 % et et qui
représente 1 % alors que B qui
représente 99 % baisse de 20 % et bien
j'ai une somme qui baisse de façon
considérable. Et puis le fait de d'avoir
toléré le chômage.
Le fait d'avoir toléré le chômage, là
aussi c'est un terme de la novellande.
Le fait d'avoir toléré le chômage
sans reconnaître réellement qu'il s'agit
de chômage. Parce que quand on dit
quand on dit à un jeune il vous suffit
de traverser la rue pour trouver un
emploi et si vous voulez je le fais à
votre place. Ça veut dire on lui dit
cher ami, tu es un fénéant, tu trouves
pas de travail parce que tu veux le veux
pas.
Tu es donc en situation de chômage
volontaire, pas de chômage involontaire.
Tu cherches pas donc tu as aucun aucune
chance d'en trouver. Et ça c'était la
thèse
d'avant les années 30 qui avait fait
dire à un grand économiste américain
au nom italien Franco Maudigliani, quel
beau nom hein qui est prix Nobel
d'économie. Il avait dit vous savez la
qu des années 30 circuler il y a rien à
voir. C'est la conséquence d'une crise
de paresse soudaine des populations.
Voilà et on recommence avec cela. Alors,
on recommence de deux façons. Une façon
euh un peu trop pouverte en disant
traverse et tu trouves.
C'est parce que tu veux pas traverser
que tu trouves pas ou en disant on va
réduire l'indemnisation du chômage. Et
réduire l'indemnisation du chômage, ça
va forcer les gens à chercher un emploi
de façon beaucoup plus active qu'il ne
faisait avant.
Parce que comme le disait dans les
années 30
un français bien connu qui s'appelait
Jacques Rf,
c'est l'assurance chômage qui crée le
chômage.
Ah ouais.
Et on est on en est là. Vous imaginez ?
On en est là. C'est raison pour laquelle
je dis il y a beaucoup de nov langues,
beaucoup de zombies qui se promènent
parmi nous.
zombies qui viennent de cette époque-là.
Ah non mais mais c'estàd que les zombies
ont former des jeunes zombies pour faire
évidemment parce que les jeunes zombies
ne peuvent faire carrière
que s'ils adoptent la doctrine zombie.
S'ils n'adoptent pas la doctrine zombie,
ils ne font pas carrière. Vous comprenez
?
Donc quand vous vous savez c'est c'est
un drame pour un professeur.
Quand un professeur qui ne pense
absolument pas comme ça
doit donner un sujet de thèse à un
étudiant,
qu'est-ce qu'il va lui dire ? Il va lui
donner un sujet de thèse qui va le
casser dans sa carrière future.
Donc un sujet de thèse qui est
antizombie
ou un sujet thèse zombie. Genre le
salaire universel.
Oui. Genre le salaire universel,
ça ça casse une carrière. Non, parce que
sal universel c'est une invention
libérale.
Donc ça fait bien
dans le décor.
Essayer de développer
le salaire universel,
c'est avec les instruments de notre
discipline. On a les moyens de faire des
modèles mathématiques extraordinairement
sophistiqués pour prouver que 1 + 1 = 2.
Bon, donc c'est ce qu'on peut faire.
pour montrer que le salaire universel
permettrait de résoudre les questions
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés de
protection sociale à condition qu'il n'y
ait plus aucune autre protection. Et ça
c'est la thèse libérale. Donc ça vous
pouvez le donner comme sujet.
Le salaire universel, le revenu
universel, vous pouvez le donner comme
sujet. Bon, par contre, vous pouvez pas
donner comme sujet la relance par la
demande
ou par l'investissement.
Vous pouvez pas donner comme sujet
et bien la Fédération européenne et les
politiques économiques qu'elle
pourraient conduire. pouvez pas donner
parce que les politiques économiques,
c'est pas bien. Ce qu'on aime nous dans
l'économie zombie, c'est ce qu'on
appelle les hands of policy,
c'est-à-dire lever les mains du de de
l'économie.
Bon,
toute la dérégulation, tout ça,
voilà.
Voilà.
On n pas besoin de vous. Occupez-vous de
vos affaires, nous on s'occupe des
nôtres.
Bon
et ça crée les dark pool derrière où il
y a des échanges sans aucune régulation,
sans aucun regard.
Ça a créé un chaos total et à plusieurs
reprises, ça a créé un chaos total.
Pourquoi on régule pas tout ça ?
Pourquoi on débarque pas et on dit
maintenant ça suffit vos conneries ?
Vous vous êtes bien amusé avec vos
petites costards, les l'année les années
tapis, les années Porsche, on se la
flambe, on se l'a fait un peu trader,
c'était cool, on fait banquier. Pourquoi
maintenant on dit pas la récréation elle
est terminée et puis maintenant on va
vous faire les poches. Pourquoi on fait
pas ça ?
Parce qu'on fait les poches à qui ?
Bah déjà, on commence par leur petits
milliards à eux.
Ouais, mais il y en a pas beaucoup.
Ouais,
il y a un effet de levier énorme sur les
machines.
J'ai pas beaucoup de petits miliaards,
hein. On fait pas un petit exemple comme
avec la Grèce
si vous voulez ce qui se passe, il eu un
phénomène
qui récemment
n'a pas échappé à votre attention. C'est
la la Bundesban qui est complètement en
faillite.
Non, c'est le fait que
les billets de 500 de 50 € ont disparu
de la circulation.
Euh 500, pas 50, 500
500 ils ont ils se ils n'existent plus.
On les fabrique plus.
50 ça dégage.
50 ça dégage. Pourquoi ?
Non mais ça c'est en Italie ça.
Non, partout
y compris en France. Pourquoi ? parce
que on a fait peser la menace d'un
prélèvement pendant la nuit sur les
comptes bancaires.
À la chipriote.
À la chipriote,
on l'aime à la chipriote. On ferme le
vendredi soir et on réouvre lundi avec
moin 50 % sur les comptes. C'est
magnifique.
Voilà.
Donc là c'est
alors là ça veut dire que tous les kidam
payent y compris
les pauvres.
Ça peut arriver en France ça.
C'est arrivé en Italie au moment de la
construction européenne et avait comme
conséquence la conséquence qu'on peut
imaginer. Les Italiens ont dit "On fait
plus confiance dans nos comptes
bancaires, on va prendre tout ce qu'on a
comme économie et acheter des
appartements dans d'autres pays." Et
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont envahi
l'Île-de- France.
Ils ont pas envahi. On les accueille
avec plaisir.
On les accueille avec plaisir.
C'est vrai. C'est
Ouais.
Revenons à nos moutons.
Euh un membre de notre communauté nous
nous attire notre attention. Il dit
"Croissance négative, ça passe mieux que
des croissances.
On nous prend pour des cons."
Attendez.
Ou bien c'est moi.
Non. Croissance négative, c'est
description de la situation dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons. Nous sommes
en situation où le PIB diminue.
Donc on est en situation de décroitation
de croissance négative
de décroissance
de non de croissance négative.
La décroissance la décroissance c'est le
concept qui est associé à l'écologie.
Pourquoi ? qui consiste à dire que si
l'on veut consommer moins de ressources
naturelles, il faut que l'on gagne
moins,
il faut que l'on consomme moins et pour
consommer moins, il faut que le revenu
baisse. La décroissance,
c'est la décroissance. Voyez, c'est une
différence assez considérable.
La croissance négative dont je parle,
c'est la réception. C'est le fait
qu'aujourd'hui,
c'est un fait. Alors, croissance
négative, c'est récession.
Récession, c'est un fait que le PIB
diminue.
C'est si vous voulez, c'est équivalent.
Les trois expressions sont équivalents.
Alors que la décroissance, c'est un
objectif que se donnent les écologistes
pour régler le problème
de l'agression de l'homme sur les
ressources naturelles.
Alors, les écologistes, oui, les
économistes, ils donnent pas ça comme
objectif. Est-ce qu'il y a des
économistes écologistes ?
Bah oui, bien sûr, il y a des
économistes écologistes. Et les
économistes écologistes
vous disent cela mais enfin euh
j'ai eu un débat avec eux
qui
et j'ai fait moi j'ai fait le
les autres en face c'était qui ?
Ah
je vais vous retrouver le nom.
il était dans ma commission donc ça va
pas être difficile.
Bon, j'avais dit j'avais fait un calcul
pour savoir
qu'est-ce qui se quel est le revenu
moyen des citoyens du monde. Parce que
si vous avez une croissance négative,
vous êtes obligé de corriger les
inégalités.
Vous pouvez pas avoir une croissance
négative pour quelqu'un qui a 100
milliards et pour quelqu'un qui a 10 €
1 €
ou 1 €
ça n'a pas de sens. Donc pour ça ait un
sens, il faut qu'il y ait une certaine
égalité qui règne. Je me suis dit quel
serait le revenu
de la planète ?
revenu individuel
pour que la planète
puisse être en situation
de départ de croissance négative ou en
d'autres termes quel est le revenu moyen
des individus de la planète et le
résultat est c'est le revenu minimum
français
c'est 450 €
450 € voilà
alors tout le monde a 450 Et à partir de
là, on décroit.
Non. Euh
ah si si
à que à partir de là,
à partir de là, on décroit.
Ouais,
ça on a actuellement, c'est ce qu'on a.
Mais demain, si on suit les préceptes
de la théorie de la décroissance, à
partir de demain, on décroit.
Pourquoi précepte ?
C'est ce qui préconisme.
Ceci préconise préconise une croissance
négative pour sauver la nature.
Croissance négative.
C'est très bizarre, vous savez. C'est
très bizarre tout ce qui se passe.
C'est nébuleux.
J'ai l'impression qu'on est dans une
confusion mentale extraordinaire.
On on c'est comme si on attachait à la
nature davantage importance ce qu'à
l'homme.
Alors que depuis toujours, on sait que
l'homme est dans un conflit permanent
avec la nature et qu'il ne s'en sort que
dans en gagnant ce conflit avec la
nature. Autrement, il aurait disparu. Il
y aurait pas de ville s'il y avait pas
de conflit avec la nature.
Vous connaît ce que je veux dire. Bon,
on va appeler mon banquier, je vous le
passe. Vous allez vous allez lui dire
"Vous inquiétez pas, il rentre en
période de croissance négative, tout va
bien se passer." En fait, on est
d'accord ?
On est en période de croissance
négative.
Non, mais là, moi aussi.
D'accord.
On va passer aux questions en internet.
Euh euh donc je suis désolé, je vais
sauter beaucoup de questions internet.
Alors question euh notre économie
peut-elle encaisser un reconfinement ?
Notre économie peut encaisser un
reconfinement
pour la raison suivante c'est que de
toutes les façons, si elle n'encaissait
pas le réconfinement, elle serait dans
un aussi mauvais état que si elle
encaissait le réconfinement.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Supposons qu'on ne reconfine pas lors
qu'on doit reconfiner.
Si on reconfine pas,
on reconfine pas. Les gens vont être
malades.
C'est du darwinisme.
Les gens vont être malades. Il va y en
avoir qui vont mourir, il y en a voilà
qui vont surir. Mais de toutes les
façons, la production va être atteinte.
Oui. Et surtout la casse politique en
premier.
Les gens la productivité va être
atteinte parce que les gens vont avoir
très peur d'aller au travail.
Ouais.
Donc en gros, imaginez que on ne
reconfine pas alors qu'on est dans des
conditions de reconfinement que les gens
vont aller travailler comme si de rien
n'était. C'est trompé totalement. On ne
va pas beaucoup gagner en terme économie
à ne pas reconfiner.
Alors question d'internet acid burn.
peut-il nous parler des dispositifs de
non paiement de l'impôt par les
entreprises comme le CICE et son
inefficacité ou son efficacité ?
Écoutez,
ma thèse est que
les politiques conduites depuis
30 ans ont été des politiques qui ont
consisté à vouloir augmenter le profit
des entreprises. Bon,
pour augmenter le profit des
entreprises, il y a deux façons. Baisser
les impôts et les charges.
entre guillemets cotisation
et ou euh deuxème
hypothèse leur donner des subventions
c'est le CCE mais le CCE va se
transformer en une baisse de charge.
Donc ça revient
baisse de cotisation
hein.
Une baisse de cotisation.
Il faut appeler un ch. Non, il y a que
vous
de tous les personnes que je connais, il
y a que vous qui utilisez le terme
correct qui est cotisation. La plupart
des autres utilisent le terme charge et
non pas cotisation.
Écoutez les programmes à la télévision,
lisez les journaux, vous verrez. ce sont
les charges sociales, pas les
cotisations sociales. Bon, donc euh je
c'est un compliment hein euh que je vous
fais. Bon,
on va boire un coup après hein.
Euh, juste une parenthèse, en 1946 quand
vous aviez euh 4 ans,
Ouais. et euh et
40 millions de personnes en France, 2,2
milliards sur terre.
On est combien maintenant ?
On est 66 milliards en France. Non, 66
millions en France.
66 millions en France.
Et combien dans le monde ?
On est 8 milliards sur Terre
environ. Euh autre question internet.
Alors bougez pas, on va en piocher une.
Ah ! Avoir le pessimisme de
l'intelligence et l'optimisme de la
volonté. Antonio Gramchi,
ça vous dit rien ?
Oui.
Vous avez voté pour qui aux dernières
élections ?
Pour qui j'ai voté ?
Ben écoutez, aux dernières élections
toute honte bu,
j'avais soutenu Macron.
Je vous assure, je ne savais pas.
Mais écoutez, vous ne savez pas ? Je
connaissais Macron bien avant.
Vous l'avez connu comment ?
par Hollande
donc je le connaissais
par l'Élysée quoi.
Et
ensuite on avait des relations agréables
mais c'était des relations d'homme de
gauche si je peux dire hein.
Euh
vous êtes fait intoxiquer.
Est-ce que je me suis fait intoxiquer ou
lui s'est fait intoxiquer ? Bah
vous d'abord et lui on sait pas, il est
pas
Non, moi je me suis fait berner.
C'est pas la même chose.
Ça fait plus mal.
Oui, ça fait plus mal parce que vous
perdez confiance, vous voyez ? Et la
confiance, c'est un élément fondamental
de la vie en société.
Si vous n'avez pas confiance, la société
devient violente.
Bon.
Et là, j'ai donc perdu confiance
parce que la politique qui a été
conduite a été exactement l'inverse de
la politique à laquelle je m'attendais.
Donc vous vous dites qu'est-ce qui se
passe ?
Et Jean-Paul, vous êtes pas un peu naïf
quand même ?
Bah écoutez, oui.
Ouais.
Tout mon but, je suis obligé de
l'avouer.
Question,
je suis naïve. Je suis même naïf par
rapport à moi. Je doute toujours de moi.
Voilà.
Ce qui est très bien.
Et le doute est sain. Question
d'Internet. Selon lui, pour les
élections de 2017, lequel des candidats
ou candidates avait le programme
économique le plus abouti ?
2017. Aucun. Bon, alors je vous
explique.
Actuellement, nous sommes dans un
système où nous avons des États fédérés.
qui sont orphelins d'un état fédéral.
En réalité, cela signifie qu'à chaque
élection,
les peuples
qui sont dans les nations
votent pour un gouvernement
et leur droit est de changer de
gouvernement.
Ils peuvent en changer tant qu'ils
veulent.
simplement,
ils n'ont pas le droit, ils n'ont plus
le droit de changer de politique.
La politique est déterminée par les
règles européennes. Ils n'ont plus le
droit de changer de politique. Donc tous
les programmes qui étaient proposés, je
le savais bien, cela ne changerait rien
à l'affaire.
Même Mélenchon,
même Mélenchon ne change rien. Regardez
CPR.
Bah, on s'attendait à ce que quelque
chose se passe en Grèce. Rien ne s'est
passé.
Si si, on a eu une sacrée téléovela
quand même. Sauf qu'il y avait des gens
qui mouraient.
On a rien. Cypras qui était de gauche
extrême est devenu de droite extrême si
je puis dire puisqu'il a laissé mourir
sa population plutôt que de s'opposer à
la troica.
Enfin, quand je dis laisser mourir sa
population, c'est une figureuse de
style. Mais il a laissé s'appliquer les
programmes d'austérité les plus violents
qu'il soit.
Dégueulasse,
dégueulasse, dégueulasse. Voahà, vous me
dites Mélenchant parce que Mélenchant
c'est mieux que Cypras, je sais pas.
Mélenchant, j'ai pas très confiance.
Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi j'ai pas très confiance en
Mélancement ? parce que il a des
affections pour des hommes politiques
qui me semblent douteux.
Lesquels ?
Comme certains hommes politiques
d'Amérique latine,
Chavez par exemple
euh comme
des hommes
du Moyen-Orient, enfin des dictateurs
disons. Voilà. Dis-moi une ryon qui
je vois mal Mélenchon avec un turbant
quand même. Non,
des dig avec un turbant mais enfin bon
il a il a besoin comme tout le monde
d'argent.
Macron il il a besoin d'argent aussi.
Tout le monde a besoin d'argent.
Donc tout le monde
fait ce qui est nécessaire pour pouvoir
conduire son combat.
C'est pas nécessairement
négatif ce que je dis, mais je dis ce
qui me déplaît
chez Mélenchon, ses amitiés qu'il
savouent et son
un racisme
qu'il n'avoue pas.
Quel racisme ? Ben
je le trouve un peu antisémite.
Vous on vous laissera vous expliquer
avec lui. Euh euh quand
dira non, il dira non. C'est évident
personne n'accepte de traiter
d'antisémite. Moi non plus.
Mais mais c'est l'impression
qu'il donne,
ça reste une impression. Donc euh
quant aux prochaines élections
présidentielles,
Macron se représente, vous votez pour
lui ?
Ben écoutez, je ne
franchement j'en ai marre. Je crois que
je voterai pas aux prochaines élections
présidentielles
parce que
si le choix est aussi restreint que
celui qui s'annonce,
si en plus le résultat est aussi assuré
que celui qui s'annonce,
je n'ai ça ne m'amuse même pas de voter.
Voilà.
pessimiste Jean-Luc quand même un peu
non
pas pessimiste mais j'ai l'impression
un réaliste
parce que je ne vois pas émerger
un troisème laron maintenant on est trop
loin de l'échéance
pourrait-on dire et un troisème laron
pourrait venir alors ça serait une
divine surprise. Jean-Luc, on se
présente.
Non mais écoutez moi Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
c'est quelqu'un que j'ai beaucoup aimé.
C'est quelqu'un que j'ai beaucoup aimé.
C'est quelqu'un avec qui j'avais des
relations lorsqu'il était ministre.
Et c'est quelqu'un que je considérais
comme étant le meilleur homme politique
de France, le meilleur tribun de France.
Pour moi, c'était
tout cuit son élection, tellement il
était bon, tellement il était supérieur,
mais vraiment
à 1000 coudés euh des autres,
un type qui connaît aussi bien
l'histoire, la culture
et et et qui a un don oratoire et un
charisme aussi important que Mélancon.
Il mérite d'avoir une place dans notre
société.
Il a pas su jouer sur ces atouts là.
Il a peut-être manqué un peu de pognon,
non ?
Hein ?
Il a peut-être un peu manqué de pognon.
Il a peut-être un peu manqué de pognon
mais vous savez pour pour faire de des
discours,
on n pas besoin tellement de pognons.
Vous voyez
pour se faire rélire quand même un
minimum
pour se faire réire. Oui.
Alors
et là il y a pas eu d'élection.
Question d'internet. Que pensent-t-il de
la théorie de la valeur et de la
critique portée par Marx et Hegels ?
Et bien, vous savez, moi je j'ai
toujours un été un admirateur de Marx.
Bon,
j'ai toujours pensé que c'était un
quelqu'un qui avait eu une vision
très important de l'avenir
et il me semble que nous sommes revenus
dans une situation marxiste,
marxienne, je dirais,
plutôt que marxiste.
C'est que les banques centrales en fait
guident prix. C'est ça.
Les banques centrales ont fait que que
la révolution ne se produise pas
parce qu'autrement la révolution se
serait produite.
Et Marx a raison parce que
l'exploitation
n'a jamais été aussi forte
qu'aujourd'hui.
Je vous donne un un un élément qui est
un élément de langage.
Vous savez aujourd'hui on appelle
le DRH
ce qu'avant on appelait le directeur du
personnel.
Directeur des ressources humaines, ça
veut dire quoi ? ressources humaines
comme les ressources pétrolières
directeur du personnel ça avait un sens
c'était des personnes.
Ressources humaines c'est des
marchandises.
Donc on est revenu à un stade
d'exploitation
où finalement le travail est de plus en
plus considéré comme une marchandise
dont la rentabilité, la compétitivité
doit être suffisante pour que les
l'entreprise puisse prospérer. on
on est revenu
à l'exploitation associée à des formes
modernes d'exploitation
qui est le harcèlement moral. dans les
entreprises, le harcèlement moral et
quelque chose de très très fréquent
et il atteint son apogé
à l'approche des 50 ans du salarié
parce que un salarié coûte plus cher à
ce moment-là et cetera. Donc
l'exploitation est là et elle a les
moyens
qui sont mis en place de cette
exploitation et on sait bien que ce qui
se passe du fait du harcèlement moral
dépasse largement l'économie puisque ça
conduit au suicide. On a eu plusieurs
exemples de suicide non ? On en parle
plus français com
par exemple
à la poste
on a eu plusieurs exemples de suicide et
dans la police nationale aussi non
pardon
dans la police nationale.
Dans la police nationale.
C'est quoi là se suicider dans son
boulot ? Ça veut dire quoi ?
C'est un appel à l'aide.
Oui. Non mais ça veut dire qu'on est
exploité. C'est pas possible d'arriver à
une telle
extrémité.
Bah,
il faut dire que quand on commence à
déchirer un petit peu des chemises, tout
de suite on va en prison. Donc bon, le
suicide c'est encore légal. Peut-être
pour ça, non ? Bon, je fais de l'ironie
l'approprié mais
c'est sûr que France Télécom, ils ont
pas eu de parachute doré mais c'est
compliqué hein.
Oui. Oui.
Question d'internet. Que pensent-il
d'Emmanuel Tod de ce qu'il dit ?
notamment sur le fait que peut-être pour
être admis à l'ENA, il faut
obligatoirement penser que l'euro
fonctionne.
Bon, Emmanuel Tod est un ami de longue
date.
On lui passe le bonjour d'ailleurs.
On oui, j'aimerais bien lui passer le
bonjour parce que on avait c'était un
peu perdu de vue depuis une dizaine
d'années et sur ce point on pense
exactement la même chose
sur le rou.
Bah oui, sur le fait que il y a alors je
m'excuse de d'y revenir parce que je
tiens dans mon livre dans mon livre je
démontre ne cassez pas votre ordinateur
je démontre bon
que en réalité
la neuve langue est un procédé
d'appauvrissement du langage.
et ce que je n'avais pas compris à son
époque, vous savez, on parlait de pensée
unique
et ça me semblait un oxy contradiction
terme à terme. Je compensais à l'époque
maintenant
me semble-t-il est devenu vrai. On a
appauvri à ce point le langage
qu'on ne peut penser que la même chose.
Gbbels qui fait ça, non ?
Et Gbs
disait cela. Or disait cela.
Et en réalité, c'est le système
d'enseignement
de des grandes écoles qui dit la même
chose. Essayer
de penser différemment, c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure, sur les thèses,
sur les sujets de thèse, essayer de
penser différemment et bien toutes les
portes vont se fermer devant vous. Vous
savez euh
j'ai voté non
à la Constitution européenne
en 2005.
On s'en fout un peu quand même. Non,
c'est passé quand même être fou.
Fallait être fou dans ma position pour
voter. Non. Et j'avais écrit mais il
fallait être encore plus fou. Fallait
j'ai même écrit un livre qui s'appelait
la politique de l'impuissance. pas
l'impuissance de la politique mais la
politique de la puissance pour montrer
que la constitution européenne
organisait l'impuissance de la
politique.
Mais là vous tombez complotiste,
attention hein.
Pardon ?
Là vous êtes complotiste là.
Non parce que elle interdisait toute
politique ni politique industrielle ni
politique de changaire.
Donc vous dites c'est quoi ça ? C'est
quoi ce pays qui n'a le droit d'utiliser
aucun de ces instruments majeurs
utilisés par les autres pays ? Donc,
j'ai écrit ce bouquin.
J'ai eu une recension de ce bouquin dans
un journal, un très grand journal.
Comment lequel ?
Je peux pas dire le nom. C'est un très
grand journal mais c'était
un journal du matin. Vous voyez ? Le
plus grand journal du matin.
C'était un article antisémite.
Voilà. C'est la première fois de ma vie,
la dernière fois.
Non, il faut avoir le nom quand même.
C'est quoi le nom Figaro
?
Et et le journaliste qui a écrit ça ?
Philippe Timono.
Voilà.
C'est votre interprétation ou c'est noir
sur blanc ? Écoutez, je vais vous dire,
j'ai retenu la phrase par cœur.
Il disait
parce que j'avais écrit ce livre,
c'était l'interview avec Jean-Claude
Guibot
et Jean-Claude Guibé à Catherine Guib
édition Harléa.
Alors, il disait tout cela fait family
business
dont l'enseigne serait beaucoup mieux à
la rue du sentier qu'à la rue de
l'odéon.
C'était quelle année ça
hein ?
C'est en quelle année ça ?
c'est au moment de la constitution
européenne
2005. C'est la première fois. Alors tous
mes amis prix Nobel ont écrit une lettre
au Figaro. Cette lettre n'a pas été
publiée.
Non,
en disant c'est inadmissible.
Surtout que ça n'avait rien à voir avec
les questions de
Oui,
c'est le principe hein. Culpabilité par
amalgame ou vous noyez dans la fange.
Voilà. Mais mais vous comprenez que il y
a vraiment une pression
pour la pensée unique.
Autrement, il y a des sanctions.
La sanction est que vous avez des
formes, des portes qui se ferment.
La sanction est que vous faites pas
carrière, vous heurtez en permanence à
des plafonds de verre.
Bon, il faut être courageux
pour penser différemment.
Donc autant penser comme les autres.
Le conformiste.
Si l'on a une famille, non, c'est pas le
confort, conformiste.
C'est parfois la nécessité. Vous voyez,
c'est parfois des gens qui ne se
sortiraient pas dans une situation
différente où il gagnerait moins.
C'est un peu le chantage qui conduit au
harcèlement moral qui fait que les gens
ne démissionnent pas tout de suite.
Peur de pas pouvoir assurer
leur quotidien. Vous voyez,
je vous ai coupé sur votre bouquin. Vous
voulez rajouter quelque chose ou je vous
pose une autre question ?
Non, je voulais simplement vous dire
cela, c'est tout. Alors, question
d'internet. Les économistes savent-ils
réellement de quoi ils parlent ?
N'ont-ils pas créé un monstre qui ne
peuvent plus comprendre ? Ne portent-ils
pas un costume trop lop
?
On peut dire ça de tous les
scientifiques.
Le problème est de savoir
quel est votre attitude par rapport à
votre savoir. Si vous avez un attitude
une attitude arrogante
comme quoi vous détenez la vérité. Alors
oui, votre interlocuteur a raison. Si
vous avez l'attitude qu'on la plupart
des économistes que je respecte,
99 % des économistes que je respecte qui
est celle d'avoir l'humilité,
de penser qu'il ne détiennent pas la
vérité, d'accepter les positions
adverses.
Alors non, c'est pas vrai. L'économie
est quelque chose qui ne consiste pas en
la création d'un monstre.
question question d'internet que
elle cherche à expliquer le monde. On
cherche à expliquer le monde. Alors pour
expliquer le monde, il nous va nous
falloir des milliers d'années.
C'est très compliqué d'expliquer le mot
mais ça ne signifie pas parce que ça va
être long qu'il ne faut pas commencer ni
continuer. Voilà.
Que pensent-t-il ? Qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la collapsologie ?
De la
collapsologie.
Je collapse.
Non, vous collapsez pas encore.
C'est quoi la collapsologie ? Vasy, on
voit le Gibolin.
C'est c'est une notion
de notre époque quand même.
Collapsologie, ça vient du collapse,
l'effondrement.
Oui, j'ai compris.
Donc, est-ce que vous pensez que notre
société peut s'effondrer ? Est-ce qu'il
faut adopter
Je vois des hommes s'effondrer, je vois
des femmes est-ce qu'il faut adopter des
mesures proactives pour limiter la la
vélocité de cet effondrement ?
Non, attendez, le le problème c'est que
nos sociétés c'est rond.
Je comprends maintenant ce que ça
signifie que la psychologie, c'est le
burnout à l'échelle de l'ensemble de la
société.
Bon, alors
la société n'est pas douée d'une volonté
qui lui est propre.
Donc, elle ne va pas euh faire son
burnout.
Mais si un nombre important de ces
membres
font leur burnout, alors la société
c'est bon. La société devient
absolument plus résilient et donc ne
peut plus encaisser le moindre choc
et elle s'effondrera
à la plus petite pichenette qu'elle
recevra par la suite.
Overstretch.
Overstretch. L'armées aime bien ce motl.
Je peux vous poser une question un peu
plus personnelle ?
Vous avez côtoyé des traders, des salles
de marché, des gens comme ça un peu non
?
Ils étaient psychologiquement stables
pour la plupart ou ils se donnaient un
vernis social ?
Est-ce que vous comprenez ma question ?
Est-ce qu'on a pas dans les salles de
marché des bandes de mégalot
complètement
cupides ?
Vous croyez que vous ne les avez que
dans les salles de marché ?
Franchement,
moi je crois qu'il y a une espèce de de
fable qui est racontée
pour essayer de repousser la faute sur
les salles de marché. Non,
la plupart des gens que je connais sont
mégalop
ont un ego considérable
et partout dans tous les domaines.
Ils ont jamais pollu l'ourpierre
dans tous les domaines. Dans tous les
domaines.
L'arrogance est quelque chose qui est la
mieux partagé dans le monde.
français.
Je vous raconte une anecdote avec
Schreder.
À un moment donné, Schreder était très
énervé.
C'était juste après le sommet de Nice,
là où il a fallu redéfinir les
pondérations des voix compte tenu de
l'élargissement de l'Allemagne.
Bon, c'était une époque où il était très
énervé et il voulait discuter avec des
intellectuels français.
Alors avec deux autres intellectuels
français, il m'avait invité
à à Berlin
payé votre voyage ou ils ont vous avez
payé votre voyage ou non ?
Oui.
Ouais.
pour dîner.
On a dîné
ensemble
et euh il disait
que dans tous les pays du monde,
les diplomates prennent les autres pour
des cons.
Seuls les Français le disent.
Ouais. Et
il voulait dire par là que l'arrogance
française avait dépassé des limites
assez intolérable. Et c'est vrai,
je l'ai vécu en étant dans des d'autres
institutions internationales comme par
exemple l'Institut universitaire
européen de Florence. Université de
Florence où j'ai passé 4 ans. Vous voyez
mes inquiétances avec l'Italie sont
nombreuses
hein.
Ce qui est facile.
Oui, c'est facile.
J'ai passé 4 ans et
donc ces acquintces avec l'Italie,
on était sur la questionage.
La l'arrogance. Oui, l'arrogance m'a
fait comprendre quelle était la
différence qu'il pouvait y avoir entre
les population en terme d'arrogance.
Les Italiens
ne sont pas arrogants, ils sont plutôt
complexés.
Du nord ou du sud ?
Florence,
c'est dans le nord, voyez.
Bon, si vous allez plus au nord vers
1000 ans, ils sont plus arrogants
parce que 1000 est le est le lieu de la
capitale économique du pays, des plus
grandes entreprises du pays. Donc
évidemment, vous rencontrez des
messieurs comme on dit,
comme à Paris,
comme à Paris, vous rencontrez des
messieurs qui sont arrogants. Mais mais
je vous raconte une autre histoire.
Euh
comment j'ai atterri à Rome ?
À Rome, ils avaient une leçon.
C'est pas à cause d'une femme.
Non, non, non,
non, non. Il y a des limites à ce que ce
que je veux vous dire.
Ils ont des leçons
qui porte un nom à la leçon Guido Carly
par exemple. Guido Carly étant un homme
très important et ils ont décidé, ils
m'ont donné une leçon qui est prononcée
tous les 2 ans
et il m'avait proposé de la faire une
fois.
Donc j'avais été comme je savais que
l'université
où je faisais cette leçon était possédée
par la cof industria. La cof industria
c'est le MEDEF italien
et que présider
le la conférence le président du MEDF
italien. J'ai décidé de faire la
conférence la plus marxiste qui soit.
Bon, j'ai fait une conférence totalement
marxiste
en disant que en réalité
les Européens voulaient le même niveau
d'inégalité que les Américains.
Ils n'arrivent pas à faire. Donc ce
qu'ils essayent de faire, c'est de
casser leur système de protection
sociale de façon à irver. Et c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils ont mis en
œuvre toutes ces politiques là. Bon,
enfin, peu importe. Euh à la fin de ma
conférence,
le président de la COF Industria qui
parlait parfaitement le français, qui
plus je parlais en italien mais lui
parlait parfaitement le français.
Beaucoup d'italiens d'ailleurs.
Oui.
Et il me dit "Écoutez, je veux
absolument que vous soyez professeur
dans cette université."
Donc vous vous dites l'ouverture quand
même d'esprit.
Il a peut-être envie de racheter son
âme.
Je sais pas mais c'est quand même une
Vous croyez en Dieu
un un ami imaginaire.
Non, j'ai un imaginaire évidemment.
Un ami imaginaire.
Oui. Vous croyez en Dieu ? Je ne crois
pas en Dieu.
Je ne crois pas en Dieu. Est-ce que j'ai
un ami imaginaire ? Oui,
j'ai un ami imaginaire.
Alors, on va passer, on arrive bientôt à
la fin de notre interview. Il y a il y a
beaucoup de questions.
Est-ce que vous avez des livres à nous
conseiller ? Au moins trois
sur quel thème ?
Le thème que vous voulez.
Mais je vous conseiller trois bouquins à
lire obligatoirement.
Je conseillerai le livre de céglise
sur les inégalités.
Le petit livre
que j'ai écrit avec Stiglis
qui s'appelle Miss measuring Our Lives
et qui a servi
de
manifeste
au mouvement Occupa et Wall Street.
Et le 3è
euh
c'est un trop beau livre ce 3è livre
mais il est très compliqué.
Euh
c'est un livre sur la démocratie
euh mais c'est un livre
d'actionatisation
de la démocratie. Ça s'appelle choix
individuel
et choix collectif.
Et c'est un livre de Kenneth Aro.
Il est très compliqué mais vous
comprenez pourquoi
il est très difficile
d'avoir une démocratie qui fonctionne de
façon huiler, si je puis dire.
Il faut il faut du sang.
Il faut du sang.
Alors un 4è, je le donne en prime, c'est
un livre d'Amartiaen.
Amartiassen, c'est un
c'est aussi un prix Nobel d'économie qui
a la
qualité d'être le seul professeur que je
connaisse qui est la double chair à
Harvard d'économie et de philosophie.
Et euh dans un livre dont je ne me
rappelle plus le nom,
avait écrit un article, un livre de ces
articles à lui avait écrit un article
qui s'appelle le fou rationnel,
rational fool.
Le faux rationnel. Le faux rationnel
c'est l'homo économicus
où il nous racontait l'histoire
suivante.
C'est quelqu'un
enfin c'est la rationalité pure, vous
voyez ? Quelqu'un qui cherche
la gare.
Il passe devant un type et il lui dit
"Est-ce que vous savez où est la gare
Le type lui dit dans cette direction lui
indiquant la direction opposée à la
gare. Il dit voyez au coin de la rue
vous avez une poste. Est-ce que vous
pouvez poster ma lettre ? Et l'autre lui
dit bien sûr je vais poster votre
lettre. Mais tout en pensant dès qu'il
me voit plus j'ouvre la lettre et je
vois ce qu'il y a dedans. Voilà. C'est
le four rationnel.
Il y en a beaucoup comme ça.
Euh, je peux vous mettre un petit tacle
d'internet ? Faire une conférence
marxiste et voter Macron en 2017, c'est
de la naïveté ou un réflexe de classe ?
réflexe de classe, je ne crois pas parce
que je n'ai jamais appartenu à une
classe quelconque.
Euh
bon, je suis une famille pour
je suis un travailleur immigré et je me
présente toujours en tant que tel.
Donc un réflexe de classe, je pourrais
pas dire
je Bon la naïveté sûrement.
C'est beau.
H c'est beau.
Pourquoi c'est beau ?
Parce que on préfère voir quelqu'un
c'est con. Non la na
mais des fois des fois c'est beau.
Question d'Internet. Son avis sur les
cryptomonnaies et peut-il nous parler du
grand reset de Christine Lagarde ?
Les cryptomonnaes, écoutez, je peux vous
donner mon avis très simplement, j'ai
jamais rien compris.
Cryptomonnaie, ce que je sais, c'est que
elles ont fait gagner beaucoup d'argent
et elles ont fait perdre encore plus à
beaucoup de gens. Bon,
donc si c'est un nouveau jeu de
monopoie, pourquoi pas ?
À nouveau
parce que le premier, il existe déjà.
C'est-à-dire l'euro, le dollar et tout
le toin.
Voilà.
On s'est compris
exactement
pour le reset de Christine Lagarde
en je suppose en tant que présidente de
la BCE.
Bah écoutez, Christine Garde c'est une
femme bien. C'est pas une économiste.
Ça on avait remarqué hein.
Hein ?
Ça on avait remarqué.
Oui, mais ça pose problème pour être la
tête d'une banque centrale. Voyez, ça
pose problème
parce qu'une banque centrale,
je je donne un exemple, il y en a qui se
croient être des économistes qui n'en
sont pas.
Jean-Je Tricher n'était pas un
économiste, c'est un haut fonctionnaire
qui a fait les NAS,
peut-être même polytechnique, mais ça
suffit pas à être un économiste.
Et vous avez eu Mario Dragiy qui était
un économiste.
Super Mario.
Ouais, le beau Mario. Enfin,
Super Mario. Et on a vu ce que les
politiques ont conduit les deux. Si on
avait conduit la politique de tricher
pendant la période du mandat de Mario
Dragué, on serait on serait mort encore.
Donc le problème est de savoir
si
Christine garde
pourra assumer cette tâche sans être
économiste. Elle a une qualité.
Elle a une grande qualité.
c'est qu'elle sait très bien s'entourer.
Elle sait très bien s'entourer. Donc au
fond monétaire international, elle avait
choisi comme chiffre économiste l'un des
économistes que je respecte le plus
qui est Olivier Blanchard
[Musique]
et
c'est aussi un coauteur.
On est ami depuis longtemps mais je
respecte beaucoup. Mais c'est
l'économiste qui lui a sauvé la mise.
Voilà. Donc c'est-à-dire et en même
temps qui a permis au fond monétaire
international d'évoluer comme jamais
dans son histoire.
Donc je me dis bon si elle a la main
aussi heureuse dans le choix de ses
collaborateurs à la banque centrale
européenne, le reset sera un succès.
DSK c'est un bon économiste.
DSK c'est un vrai économiste
ou pas ?
Vous nous conseillez de l'inviter ou pas
?
Est-ce que vous nous conseillez de
l'inviter ?
Oui oui, c'est un bon économiste. C'est
un type qui a beaucoup de choses à dire.
C'est un type pour lequel j'ai
de l'estime et de l'amitié.
Bon,
chacun a ses dysfonctionnements.
Ouais. À ce niveau-là, c'est plus un
dysfonctionnement. Ça s'appelle une
grosse pathologie quand même hein.
Oui oui
oui
oui mais enfin je vais pas en vouloir
connaissez
parce que les hommes malades quoi.
Est-ce que vous connaissez Ga Girou ?
Gel Girou celui qui s'occupe
le prêtre
d'impôt à
le prêtre.
Je je l'ai rencontré au siècle.
Au siècle ?
Ouais.
He
ouais.
Alors
ça a l'air d'être un type très bien.
Ga Girou au siècle, j'ai pas compris, il
me semble.
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
propositions ?
Je les connais pas.
D'accord. C'était une question internet.
On a fini avec les trois bouquins. Là,
c'est la dernière question que je vais
vous poser. Est-ce que vous pouvez
montrer votre livre 2 secondes là ?
Parce qu'on a pas beaucoup parlé.
Il y a marqué quoi dessus ?
Il y a marqué comme on nous parle
le l'emprise de la neuve langue sur nos
société.
Est-ce que je peux vous demander de
piocher une page dedans et de me lire un
paragraphe ?
Bien sûr.
Piocher, ça veut dire pas choisir, hein.
Non, non. Voilà, je j'ai pioché la page
que vous m'aviez pioché en mettant votre
truc. Vous voyez ?
Bon.
Les travailleurs
ont perdu ce qu'il leur restait
d'autonomie.
Constamment soumis qu'ils sont un
jugement fondé sur différents critères
établis par les directions des
ressources humaines. Comme on dit,
l'arbitraire n'est pas absent de ce
processus de jugement
apparemment objectif accentuant l'état
d'anxiété dans lequel se trouve le
salarié. L'objectif est encourager les
personnes à travailler, ce qui implique
qu'elles n'y sont pas naturellement
disposées. Il faut donc surveiller,
récompenser et punir ce que permet
l'ensemble du dispositif. Voilà.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? de ne pas être
salarié,
d'être patron,
d'avoir des professions indépendantes,
d'être patron si possible
ou d'avoir des professions indépendantes
et et s'ils sont patron de penser à ce
que les salariés sont des êtres humains
et pas des ressources humaines. Voilà,
Jean-Paul Fit aussi, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]